soleil est taux de change favorable
c'est le cocktail de l'été du tourisme
régional
un mélange à succès 13 % de
fréquentation a plus que l'an dernier
les journées mondiales de la jeunesse
n'explique pas tout les touristes
étrangers sont venus en force
traditionnel japonais anglais américains
mais aussi beaucoup d'italiens et de
brésiliens pour l'économie locale
tous n'ont pas le même poids on a
observé sont des moyennes qu'un tourisme
japonais dépensé environ 700 francs par
jour à touristes américains environ 900
francs par jour
il ya donc de grandes disparités mais en
tout état de cause tous les touristes
apporte à nos professionnels et apporte
à l'emploi en ile de france qui
représente beaucoup peint au niveau du
tourisme 750 mille emplois directs et
indirects environ chaque année
paris n'est pas seule à tirer son
épingle du jeu exemple dans l'essonne où
le passeport du comité du tourisme a été
distribué à 15000 exemplaires une
formule de promotion à tarif réduit les
activités du département
ici les gîtes ruraux ont affiché complet
tout l'été échanges nouvelle anglais
espagnol ils sont pour une large part
l'essonne est plus habitué au tourisme
de proximité
mais la saison n'est pas finie la saison
touristique est belle va se prolonger au
mois de novembre avec les vacances de
novembre et elle se prolonge aussi
pendant les week-ends et la chaussure
qu'avec la température qu'il fait
l'humidité
on va avoir une belle saison de
champignons ça va nous attirer également
des touristes
auvers-sur-oise barbizon versailles et
euro disney sont les autres grands
succès de l'été francilien sur les 35
millions de visiteurs annuels de la
région plus d'un tiers séjourne
désormais hors de paris